مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتدعي حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه في
مختلف الصعد ستنضم الينا من نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه هيا ايوب منسقه التواصل
لجمعيه من حق اسمع وسنس الضوء على معاناه
فاقد السمع من الاطفال الفلسطينيين التي
تفاقمت مع اجتياز الحرب على غزه عتبه المئ
يوم نشير في البدايه الى اعلنته وزاره
الصحه في غزه الى ان 70% من ضحايا الحرب
الاسرائيليه هم اطفال ونساء كما قال
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي ان هناك 7000
مفقود تحت الانقاض او مصيرهم مجهول
وبالارقام ايضا تظهر الماساه الانسانيه
التي يعيشها الاطفال الفلسطينيون من ذو
الاعاقه السمعيه كما
نشاهد سبعه اضعاف هي نسبه فقدان السمع
والبصر في قطاع غزه مقارنه بالنسب
العالميه
35050 طفلا فلسطينيا فاقدا للسمع بحاجه
لزراعه القوقعه السمعيه
سنويا سبعه اطفال من كل الف طفل في قطاع
غزه يولدون فاقدين للسمع وبحاجه لزراعه
القوقعه السمعيه ايضا مئات طفل في قطاع
غزه خضعوا لزراعه القوقعه
السمعيه الان من جديد ارحب بالاستاذه هيا
ايوب منسقه التواصل لجمعيه من حق اسمع
اهلا بك استاذه هيا الوضع في قطاع غزه صعب
اصلا
اي حدثينا اكثر عن طبيعه منظمتكم في الوقت
والوضع الطبيعي ما قبل هذه
الحرب نعم شكرا لك جمعيه من حق اسمع هي
منظمه غير ربحيه بطبيعه الحال وقبل الحرب
هذه الجمعيه هدفها انها تساعد وتمكن
الاطفال ضعفي السمع وخاصه الاطفال اللي
بينول بمشكلات سمعيه يعني بحاجه لتدخل
مباشر هذه الجمعيه تاسست عام 2019 وبتعتمد
بشكل اساسي على العمل الخيري وعلى
التبرعات لحتى تقدم ثلاث امور اساسيه هي
الامور هي بدايه العمليه الجراحيه اللازمه
لزراعه القوقعه السمعيه واللي هو هي الحل
السمعي الاساسي اللي بتحاول تقدمه الجمعيه
الامر الثاني مساعده الاطفال على التاهيل
السمعي واللفظي وايضا دمجهم في المجتمع
والامر الاخير وهو التوعيه بالصحه السمعيه
الجمعيه بتساعد بالخصوص يعني في قطاع غزه
اكثر من 100 حاله حاليا وطبعا خارج القطاع
تعمل الجمعيه في الضفه الغربيه وتعمل ايضا
في مناطق اخرى في يعني بلاد الشام نعم
ماذا عن الوضع الان اثناء الحرب ما هي
ابرز التحديات والصعوبات التي تواجهكم نعم
من بدايه الحرب احنا مع الاسف يعني فقدنا
منسقنا الاساسي للجمعيه السيد عماد سليم
نترحم عليه هو استشهد هو وباقي افراد
عائلته فخسرنا صراحه في الكوادر البشريه
ايضا من بدايه الحرب تعرضت المراكز اللي
موجود فيها المعدات و الاجهزه اللازمه
لهدول الاطفال وبالتالي تضررت يعني اغلب
هي المراكز بمعداتها باجهز تها حاليا كمان
غير موجوده الطواقم اللي كانت تشتغل
والشركاء ايضا المحليين عم نحكي على
اخصائيين السمع والنطق غير قادرين انهم
يتواصلوا مع الاطفال وغير قادرين انهم
يقدموا الاحتياجات الاساسيه لهي الفئه
اللي بال يعني بالفعل هي بحاجه ل مساعده
اكثر من غيرها بالاضافه لذلك ايضا
المستشفيات اللي كانت شريكه معنا هي ايضا
كمان تضررت وبالتالي حتى العمليات
الجراحيه اللي كنا بالسابق عم بقوم فيها
بتقريبا شهريا توقفت بالكامل فحاليا
المتضررين من الاطفال هم اكثر من 100 طفل
وطفله زارعين للقوقعه وفي منهم فقدوا
الاجهزه الخارجيه اللي بتساعدهم على السمع
وعننا ايضا عشرات الاطفال حجم
الضر ما نفهمه منك انكم لم تتمكنوا خلال
هذه الفتره نحن نتجاوز اليوم نتحدث عن 104
ايام من عمر هذه الحرب لم تتواصلوا نهائيا
مع الاطفال من ذوي الاعاقه السمعيه او اي
احد من
ذويهم يعني نتواصل بصعوبه شديده لانه احن
نتواصل معهم باستخدام الواتساب من من
الضفه الغربيه و طواقمنا في الضفه يعني
بالكات تتواصل مع البعض منهم ولكن في
الحالات القليله اللي احنا تواصلنا مع
هذول الاطفال وذويهم قدرنا انه نشوف انه
في حاجه كثير ملحه لكثير منهم لها اجهزه
وقطع اساسيه لحتى يسمعوا شو عم بصير او
يحاولوا هذول الاطفال يفهموا ويتواصل مع
اهاليهم
لاستيعاب الامور من حولهم ف صحيح الصعوبه
يعني كبيره جدا بالتواصل ولكن في في نوع
خلينا نحكي من التواصل اللي مكنا من حصر
يعني الاحتياجات الاساسيه لهدول الاطفال
ومع طبيعه الحال يعني نن غير قادرين على
تقديم ه الاحتياجات حتى بعد تواصلنا مع
الاطفال طق اخرى هل من طرق اخرى او خطط
اخرى بالاحرى لدى منظمتكم للتعامل مع هذه
الازمه نعم بالتاكيد احنا حاليا عم نعمل
على جمع المعلومات قدر الامكان للاطفال
وذويهم من خلال شركاء محليين ومن خلال
كمان اخصائيين السمع بالاضافه لذلك بنحاول
انه احنا نشوف مؤسسات دوليه موجوده
للمساعده في في تقديم الاحتياجات الاساسيه
ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذه نقطه مهمه جدا انه
انا اشير لها كثير من الاحتياجات ها اللي
الاطفال هي بحاجه لها هي مكلفه نوعا ما
وبالتالي بحاجه لبعض الوقت للجمعيه لحتى
تستطيع انها توفر المستلزمات خلينا نحكي
وتمنها للاطفال بالتالي ما هي رسالتكم في
هذا الاطار للمنظمات
المعنيه الرساله صراحه هي رساله ايه منظمه
انسانيه خيريه بتحاول انها توصل ل
فئات يعني ذو احتياجات خاصه بالفعل بحاجه
لانها يعني يوصلها الاجهزه لحتى تقدر
تتفاعل مع الناس اللي حواليها تفهم لحتى
تقدر كمان العائله المحتضن لهدول الاطفال
خلينا نقول تحتضنها تقدم لها الرعايه
الاساسيه لانه صحيح ممكن في مستلزمات هلا
اشد يعني ضروره الناس في غزه ولكن ايضا
هذه الفئات رح تتضرر بشكل نفسي ممكن كثير
اكثر من غيرها بسبب يعني عدم توفر
الاحتياج اللي بكنها من السمع والتواصل مع
غيرها شكرا جزيلا لك هيا ايوب مسقه
التواصل لجمعيه من حق اسمع كنت معنا من
نابلس شكرا جزيلا لك بهذا وصلنا الى ختام
هذه النافذه الانسانيه